welcome back to PJ chain Design This is
PJ today I would like to show you how to
create this flower pendant with the
prong set right in the middle with the
Rhino 3D software are you ready let's
get
[Music]
started we are going to bring in the
stone and size it up for whatever size
is going to fit your design in my case
I'm going to do something roughly about
mm after that we want to uh work on the
prong first so I'm going to draw a line
coming over here and if that is too
taper and I might want to go a little
bit straight there okay all right so
we're simply going to pipe this one so
let's go ahead to using the pipe command
and coming over for roughly about 1
mm size there so I now I have this prong
I'm going to uh having a six pedal later
on so I'm going to make it into six prom
by polar array and the number is six
here and we will get something like this
so now we have prong and we wanted to
make sure that it is sitting on
something so I'm going to go with the
threp point and snapping somewhere not
snapping but going somewhere about here
and coming down something like this all
right so I may also want to tell it the
a little bit just follow you know the
shape of that all right so now we have
that maybe a little bit
wider we want to use the command under
the surface you have revolve and
snapping into the zero hold the shift
and we want
360° so now you can see we have a botton
there all right so let me temporary just
group them together just in case we
might need to change something the prom
position or something like that and let
me change this into the Scion color all
right so now we have this we wanted to
work on the paddle so the way I'm going
to work on the padal is I need to create
the overall shape first so again I'm
going to use a rectangle coric cornner
snapping in center for the zero here and
the padal it's about depends on how big
you want them to be so I'm roughly want
have something like this and coming down
something a little bit rounded all right
so this will be the shape and let me
temperate the height this setting in the
middle so it's easier for you to see now
I'm going to draw a curve starting from
the end point over here holding the
shift this is super important the first
one you want to make sure that you go up
right and then we're going to come in
over
here and pass the center point there and
we want to draw a straight line snapping
into the zero and make sure that this
one can turn it off this one now we need
to creating the surface so the way we
are going to create this surface it's
going to be rail revolve and you're
going to pick up his profile this is
Rail and we want to go from here and
going down or going up either one will
work so then we will have this surface
all right if you feel like this is too
much of an angle you might need to
adjust
the uh curve that you have uh if you
wanted to be less angled than this
profile so now we have this one let's go
ahead to draw a straight line and this
line need to pass the shape of what you
have
there and let me turning this into the
red color so it's easier for you to see
all right so then I'm going to have uh
six pedal so I'm going to using the
polar array snapping in to the zero and
instead of six I need to have 12 of them
for something like that okay so before
we project I would like to actually
rotate this uh 15° so that way my pedal
one of the pedal will be right at 12:00
and let's go ahead to project this one
to this
surface and we also want to make a new
layer that me bring them to that layer
and also change change the color to
something we can separate them for green
one okay so now we don't need everything
else but those line here all right so I
would like to design the pedal um I'm
going to draw on the side my pedal is
going of coming up and something like
this and kind of dip it in and coming
back on the back I want them to be nice
and rounded so something like that okay
and then we want to move this one to
this place so we are going to come in to
the transform and we have the oriented
two point and make sure we want to copy
and the scale is
3D and we want to snaping um into any of
the near point maybe somewhere about
here coming over here and we want to
snaping here to
here here to
here this one to this
one and maybe we just going to work on
three of them and it will just mirror to
the bottom so instead of doing bunch of
them okay and um if I turn it back to
see my stone so the pedal doesn't have
to go all the way to the middle and so
I'm going to um just creating a circle
and somewhere about here as long as it
is uh inside of that stone so that will
be fine so we are going to trimate
everything in the middle so now we have
this in in order to making the surface
we are going to use the sweep to rail
this is rail one rail to and
crosssection okay so notice that um the
thickness is changing too it's it's
because the rail is coming together so
it is thickness is changing as well and
we want to maintain High here so we'll
maintain a good thickness it's much
better for the casting okay so that is
one there and I'm going to continue with
the sweep to rail this
one and another one over
here so now I have this uh we need to
deal in with the bottom for the bottom I
like it nice and round here so if we
just cap this
one and then we're using the fill
edges and it will be something like that
even though you say you want to have a
bigger fitter edges let's try uh maybe 6
mm that might still be okay but I really
like it to be super puffy so here's what
I'm going to do let go back one step and
I'm going
to kind of hiding this one so it's
easier for you to
see in fact let's change to darker green
color all right so this one is going to
be split
by this curve and this curve so now it
become two of them and then I'm going to
uh making an arc snapping into snapping
into the midpoint here and midpoint
there and coming over to my right view
hold a shift so then you got this really
nice bump there to making the surface we
want to use a sweep to
rail and you want to go from this point
to this Arc
back to this
point so then we will have a puffy one
over there okay so now we have this
puffy one if we go back and turn on our
render view you should see them going
smoothly it's almost
like no Gap there okay and so double
check if that work for you you're going
to do the same to this one or that one
or we can do a easy way
by using the same command we used
earlier for Orient 2 point and I want to
pick up this one Orient from this point
to this point and uh make sure you want
to copy and scale 3D and we want to go
to this point to this point and
again this point to this point let's go
ahead to pick up all of them
and join
together okay so double make sure that
they do join um and we want to use a
command cap on all three of them so they
uh close solid poly surface so that's
what we're looking for and we do want to
have them uh mirror to the other side so
that's using the mirror uh snapping into
the zero and then so we'll have that
there okay okay let's create another
layer here and I'm going to change this
layer into the red color and so what we
wanted to do for the small pedal you can
you can create exactly process again or
you simply can making a copy to this new
lay I would like to have them rotated
30° and make them
smaller all right so I'm a little bit
lazy on that but that work for me and
then we'll have something like this turn
back to uh for the stone that we have
and make sure your stone is in the right
position and all you need to do is have
another Bell so when you finish they
will look something like this I hope you
enjoy this video if you like to know
more about the stone setting I have a
stone setting mini course specific
design for the beginner it's starting
with the stone setting concept and we
will do a demo for the prong set and I
will also show you how to custom a pron
set hat check out the link at the
description below it's completely free
for you so hope to see you there thank
you for watching and I'll see you next
[Music]